and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review get smart
oh my god the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life
this this guy called Maxwell Smart who
looks an awful lot like the guy from the
office and he has all sorts of gadgets
like a special pocket knife a special
belt buckle and is sure that he can talk
to I used to talk to my shoes but we're
not on speaking terms anymore and
there's this woman made 99 oh she's a
perfect 10 in my book I mean she is so
attractive I feel so bad that she
married that gay cowboy and Brokeback
Mountain she deserves so much better
like I could be your ideal man she'd be
like are you a cowboy no are you gay no
okay that's that's x-ray and somebody
told me that there was a rock in it but
all I saw is this guy who looked like a
wrestler who liked to raise his eyebrows
or not and there's this guy who's in a
tree I'm not kidding a man who's
actually in a tree I was in a tree once
but I'm renovating it now so the spies
are out to stop the evil Siegfried I
knew it was no good what was he training
those white tigers for anyway aside from
gay sex and they find all these nuclear
weapons that are hidden in a big meal
and why we could never find the weapons
of mass destruction they were hidden in
bakeries that's probably where Osama bin
Laden is hiding - he's probably staked
out in a Panera Bread and I like to
fight this huge giant guy I mean he is
huge it's like if Andre the Giant and
lurch have a love child that my friends
steroids - every day while stretching
him so Maxwell's Martin 99 had to stop
this concert hall from blowing up which
is probably not a good idea
next week I hear they're doing Philip
Glass let it burn so there's this car
chase a plane chase and a train chase
all at the same time it's like if
Michael Bay traffic planes trains and
automobiles so Maxwell Smart is fighting
the rack
I guess he's between a rock and a hard
place but I digress and in the middle of
the battle
they kiss each other I mean it actually
kiss each other where else can you see
Steve Carell in the rock kissing each
other and I thought Seyfried what's up
to no good
they should have called it a smart that
would have been more appropriate
so Maxwell Smart saves the day by
tackling a conductor don't all great
movies in that way and then you get the
scenes but shakes what is up with this
bull baby there is way too much man love
going on here and at the end they're
like you should become a secret agent
and Maxwell Smart is like now and go
back to the office - I'll miss me and
let me play the classic Get Smart theme
song it's Marty great date but he isn't
gay sometimes anyway kiss the right
today guess that's okay okay bet you
didn't know I used to be a singer but my
career was more important come on